there is also much to the game
politically and financially from the
growing fascination with these historic
talks and Ben Tracy it's following that
part of the story here in Singapore Vann
good morning Jeff good morning a lot of
the anticipation for this summit is
because you have these two very
unpredictable world leaders sitting down
face to face and coming into this
meeting you've seen Kim Jong moon in the
eyes of the world go through a pretty
big transformation from something of a
madman to something of a statesman but
of course that kind of diplomatic pivot
does require some explaining back in
North Korea because for decades the US
has been seen there as North Korea's
greatest threat now earlier today state
media North Korea explained that the
summit is the result of what they're
calling changing times it set a new
relationship with the u.s. comes from
the desire to build a permanent
peacekeeping mechanism and the eventual
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
it also noted that the talks are taking
place under the great attention of the
whole world and here in Singapore that
attention is evident restaurants and
businesses are cashing in you can find
summit themed dishes Trump and Kim
t-shirts and for good measure
a pair of impersonators who are holding
mock press conferences now Singapore
says it spent about twenty million
dollars to be the host of this summit so
perhaps they'll get some of that money
back from tourists who are going to buy
some summit sweat
all right then thank you very much we
did just returned from the summit
location Sentosa Island a highly unusual
scene at this hour there are beaches and
battleships very busy shipping lane most
of those ships have been cleared out
except for a military presence and then
the hotel the capella hotel where these
two leaders will sit face to face very
soon we're gonna have much more on the
summit tonight on the CBS Evening News
live from Singapore for now back to Nora
in New York those details are so
interesting Jeff Glor and Singapore
thank you